ariana debose joining us right now good
morning how are you doing good morning
and thank you that's so nice of course
you look fantastic um so we have the
tonys coming up yes you performed at the
tony before i did back in 2018 i was a
tony nominee then i also lost that
evening that's okay though that's okay
things have changed since then
speaking of one of those changes you'll
be hosting the tonys this year how do
you feel
you know to quote the late great stephen
sondheim i am excited and scared
but that's the beauty of live theater
you know the tonys are the theater
community's like biggest night where we
celebrate all the greatest work of the
season and this year is really special
because we're celebrating the entire
community we are returning to radio city
for the first time since the pandemic
and we are live coast to coast so it
feels like we're coming back bigger and
better and i'm excited to celebrate our
entire community not just the headliners
you know that was the most interesting
thing to me is this idea this year on
broadway for people who went
under studies yes played such a huge
role because with coveted restrictions
people were just going and it was last
minute you've been an understudy
is there a way to pay tribute to them at
the tony
then trust me i promise you this i have
many things up my sleeve oh i do i have
many things up my sleeve and it's from a
real genuine place because the reality
is those are the folks who have kept
broadway alive and it's not just swings
and understudies it's also dance
captains associates stage managers um
everyone in the pit there have been
several accounts of musicians who have
had to call out last minute and somebody
who's literally down the street shows up
with their instrument and just plays a
score they've never seen before helping
us to save the show and keep the show
going and so those are the folks that
we're focused on shining very genuine
bright light on because the show must go
on that's right you can't do it without
every single person i am neither an
award-winning or award-losing tv
your name is tony i've never been
nominated for anything as far as i know
tomorrow but for all the people who are
going to be there in the audience who
have been nominated at the tony awards
uh it's got to be a weird psychological
space because you got to be ready to
celebrate but also ready to be kind of
let down like what advice do you have
for them smile
and you know what here's the thing i
think that tony's like having had the
privilege to participate in a few award
shows this past season i love the tonys
there's a different energy to it and
it's one of the most friendly warm
energetic rooms and at the end of the
day it's still about community you know
it takes so much effort to get to this
moment and so for me being in the room
that's the win
[Music]
you mentioned the word moment and you
had a moment when you accepted your
oscar and in that speech you said to
anybody who has ever questioned your
identity or find yourself living in the
great spaces i promise you this
there is indeed a place for us
how far have we come when it comes to
representation not just on stage in
broadway but in hollywood in general
you know if i'm honest like for me from
where i sit we've taken many steps
forward that doesn't mean there's not
still work to be done amen to that you
know and i think one of the beautiful
things about my journey is i now have a
seat at the table and i take it as my
personal responsibility to try and
create more seats
and shine light where i can now that
doesn't mean i can solve all the world's
problems right but what i can do is
continue to ask questions and bring the
folks along who i know can tell the
story better than me can you know yeah i
was gonna say can you not solve the
world's problems you're on a big list
time 100 most influential people all the
problem solvers i'm gonna be honest with
you tony that was crazy
i did not see that one coming i really
didn't i'm i'm truly honored to be on
the list and it is a very
powerful influential formidable group of
people and i think when we all use our
powers for good
that we can create meaningful change but
i can tell you something
it's the powers for good part that i'm
interested in that's right so you know
i i'm looking forward to celebrating at
tonight's gala and you know maybe i'll
ask some questions there yeah
thinking back to that thinking back to
your oscar nominated for tony's all of
this
in the last couple of years how have
things changed for you i mean have you
been able to reflect on where you are
now you can host the tonys on sunday i
mean
if you have reflection on some of that i
have
i'm i'm someone who life has changed
considerably in a short amount of time
you know a lot can happen in a year that
can happen in two years um but i i
really did go from being a name that
people only recognized if you'd seen me
on broadway
to um you know you recognize ariana
dubose a little more now you know yeah i
don't consider myself famous though
i really don't i'm still an artist just
trying to make a difference in her
community but i can tell you this
i am grateful that when i do
speak up when i do decide to use my
voice nine times out of ten now when i
am in the room
i'm grateful that people listen yeah and
that's why i'm like your voice has power
please use it in whatever way that you
can but also invite people to the table
to the conversation with you
you know we can't we talk about change
and wanting meaningful change but we
can't make it happen if we don't make
space for all of us and the difference
of opinion i think discord is good but
we have to also find the balance and the
compromise of course let me get off
myself
we are hearing every word you are at a
great place in life and you are
maneuvering through this space with
amazing grace you may not think you're
famous but the people who stop you at
the grocery store they think you're fake
that's for sure ariana debose you are
the best thank you so much you can see
the 75th annual tony awards this sunday
night at 8 eastern right here on cbs and
streaming live of course on paramount
plus